that was my that was my attempt to use
it click baby title but actually not
really though because it's kind of true
[Music]
hey what is up guys Thank You Bhd here
and I think if you asked a lot of people
what phone they think I use like what
phone you think mkbhd uses they probably
would have said pixel 2 and I wouldn't
blame you that's typically what it is
I've said before in videos I carry two
phones my iPhone of choice and my
Android phone of choice that would be
iPhone 10s my favorite iPhone and
usually pixel two and like I've used a
lot of Android phones this year and nine
times out of ten when I'm done testing
them when I take my sim card back out
and get to choose what to put it back in
as my daily driver it's usually back in
a pixel I've said that in videos now
sometimes for various reasons there are
other phones that are really tempting to
stick with and that's fine I have no
allegiance so as soon as I like a phone
better that's the one I'm gonna stick
with I'm fortunate enough to be in that
position so like the hundred twenty
Hertz display on the razor phone was
incredible it felt like it was spoiling
me and it was really hard to leave that
but eventually I did and I went back to
the pixel to daily because of that
camera I did say that in the review
video and Galaxy S nine Galaxy S nine
screen is so damn good it's obviously
Samsung's made the best displays in the
business for a little while now and just
the Galaxy S nine plus as an overall
package the better hardware the glass
and metal I think Lou from unbox therapy
he recently made a video about why he's
using that phone as his daily driver and
it was tempting but at the end of the
day I went back to the pixel to for my
software preferences and at superior
camera in fact it pretty much always
came down to the camera obviously a lot
of other phones are better than pixel in
plenty of other ways but the pixel twos
camera is from my usage so much better
so vastly better than others that it was
hard to give up as someone who shoots a
lot of videos and takes a lot of photos
you've seen my Twitter and my Instagram
the pixel 2 was a must-have in my pocket
plus things like the colored power
button the stock Android the Google
assistant front-facing speakers all the
stuff didn't hurt but lately it's
changed over the last few months I've
ping pongs back and forth between my
pixel 2 XL
and one plus six and you know three
weeks here a month there to exceed two
weeks there just back and forth but
lately I've landed on and my SIM card is
in right now the one plus six at least
for right now I mean it's not really
like one of these phones is drastically
better than the other one plus six is
obviously a bit newer so it's got new
respects snapdragon 845 versus 835 it
has eight gigs of ram versus four gigs
and if I'm nitpicking I think the
overall build quality is better it has a
headphone jack it has better clicky ER
buttons it has the alert slider all the
stuff I talked about in the full review
is still true but the pixel on the other
hand on top of that great camera it has
that colored power button it has a
fingerprint reader that I think is a
little bit better it has the squeeze for
the assistant it has day one software
updates and peer stock Android and of
course the front-facing speakers all
this stuff I said in that review is also
still true but the tilt that keeps
sending me over from pixel back to one
plus six is performance that's been a
difference the other day one of my
friends artem from Android Police
tweeted something that actually run home
with me a lot he said his pixel two is
devastatingly and embarrassingly laggy
both on Oreo and Android P it's been
like that for months and he hates using
it and the only reason he's sticking to
it is the camera and his one plus six is
roughly 700 times snappier but the
camera isn't as good so he's basically
forced to stick with the pixel that more
or less has been this same experience
I've had swapping back and forth between
these phones using them over and over
again I found the same thing my pixel
two has felt like it's slowed down much
more than other phones have in the same
amount of time I've owned it I mean it's
not mine's not devastatingly and
embarrassingly laggy and sloped but it's
noticeable for me I look at animations a
lot a lot of transitions a lot of
swiping a lot of movement and this is
not holding animations at the 60fps
anymore like I kind of assumed it could
and would for a while and it's less than
a year old so it's just weird actually
thought it was because I was trying
obviously you saw those videos the
Android P Developer Preview on this
phone and maybe that would be
responsible for some slowdown so I
actually got another phone specifically
to never put a beta on this phone and
just use it as a daily driver and now
both of these phones are slow strange
that
it's not made a difference and all the
while this is going on the 1 plus 6
which has been sitting as like my second
favorite android phone has been just as
smooth and fast as the day I got it
snappy it's hard to appreciate in video
form because the pixel 2 is basically
almost every bit as fast as the 1 + 6 as
far as like opening and closing apps and
things like that but the 1 plus 6 is way
snappier and quicker feeling because of
the animations holding their frame rates
the transitions and movements are all
smoother and dropped less frames like I
can tell that for certain with my eye
just looking at it and it's significant
enough to the point where I notice it
between the two and it does bother me
the weird part is usually you would
expect a phone with stock Android
especially a pixel or a nexus or
anything from this line to be a plus
optimization because Google controls the
experience from the top-down hardware to
the software so this should be the
smoothest fastest Android phone right
but it's not you can also see after
multitasking for a while it starts to
drop apps from memory faster and that
makes a difference when you're using a
phone all day if you have to keep
reloading apps all the time and waiting
an extra bit this is a real-world
difference between actually 4 gigs of
ram and 8 gigs of ram a couple years ago
I would have said it doesn't really
matter 1 plus you could safely say was
putting extra RAM in phones just to
impress people who look at the spec
sheet but now I'm actually observing it
make a real-world difference basically
this whole experience highlights the
always tough part about reviewing
electronics specifically a smart phone
because you don't really fully know how
it's going to bear out durability wise
in the future you're guessing I mean you
can tell when something feels
high-quality and you know when build
quality and materials are good that
it'll physically hold up but you never
really know down the line of things like
the flash storage or the RAM are going
to degrade faster than usual or slow
down things like that you just kind of
find out when they happen like a lot of
times it's easy to preach like oh you'll
never know the difference between a
Snapdragon 835 and 845 or between 6 gigs
and 8 gigs of ram and that sometimes
it's true when you first get the phone
but later down the road sometimes you do
see those differences play out like I'd
be curious if there's other if you're a
fair pixel 2 or pixel 2 XL owner out
there if you've had performance drops or
what your experience is because again
this is
we'll definitely by far the best camera
in any smartphone and that's what makes
it such an appeal besides all the other
things about stock Android and what it
does well but the performance so it's
the speed of the one plus six plus a
couple other smaller preferential things
it's it's mostly preference but I do
like to build quality better I do like
the screen better the buttons are better
but it's what's turned me over to using
this phone full time and enjoying that
experience but I miss this camera so
much but then also I know we're all very
excited to see what's gonna happen with
the next pixel the pixel 3 I think just
the mere possibility of a smartphone
camera being better than what we already
have in the pixel 2 is nuts
plus a display can't possibly have the
same issues as this one so it'll be
better it'll probably have front-facing
speakers it'll be first in line for
software updates will complete the whole
integration of HTC and Google
controlling the whole experience it
should be awesome I'm looking forward to
that phone but then also as far as we
know just because of the way Google
operates this one will probably also
have 4 gigs of RAM and not six or eight
and we also of course got those leaks of
the gigantic like really big notch
bigger than we expected I don't know I
guess the moral of the story is one it's
hard to know how electronics especially
smartphones are gonna break down
internally in the future I mean we can
all kind of tell just based on build
quality and construction and how they're
made if they'll hold up physically but
internally you know when things start to
slow down or they break down before
they're supposed to really that's always
a weird thing even if it's an isolated
incident I've had two different pixel
two excels slowdown the same way that's
why I'm curious what your experience has
been with yours but also too it also
says something good about the state of
smartphones when I actively choose and
use every day a 500 something dollar
phone in a world where I'm surrounded
especially even in this studio by 900 to
$1,100 phones that you could also use so
that's a good sign but basically
preference is everything and priority
your own priority is everything when it
comes to picking something as personal
as a smart phone you're gonna use every
single day but that's why I've landed on
one plus six for right now you might not
have known
now you do and I got my eye on that next
pixel I got my eye on the next galaxy
note that's about to come out I got my
eye on the next iPhone that's about to
come out there's a whole bunch of stuff
it's kind of like that
pre holiday season electronics dump that
we're about to see I'm excited for it
but until then now you know thanks for
watching
tots you guys in the next one peace